[Music]
this is a new look I've been working on
my pecs yeah
the costumes tough to get into is it a
drag is it kind of fun at the same time
actually wearing them getting in and out
of them and you don't you know you could
think he was pink after all these years
doing these kinds of films they would
sort of have that part of it so
superhero suits not so comfortable but
while Michaels making his return to the
ant-man movies Michelle's the newcomer
to the franchise and she caused quite a
buzz on I've actually worked with her in
the past that's right she played your
love interest and now yeah and now she's
playing your girlfriend's mom I mean
it's good right shot partly on the
streets of San Francisco ant-man and the
wasp has these Hollywood legends playing
classic comic book characters but it's
not the first time Michelle's ventured
into that world she cracked her whip as
Catwoman back in 1992 it's the big
difference for you I was learning how to
use a whip I was kickboxing I think
everything was really more practical
there was very little special effects
that's what you call it practical right
yeah
[Music]